I understand that President Trump is
going to meet with congressional leaders
tomorrow to try to hammer out a daca
deal Democrats and establishment
Republicans desperately want some kind
of legal status for the nearly 800,000
illegal immigrants unrolled under the
deferred action for childhood arrivals
the so-called dreamers well that gives
the president a lot of leverage to get
what he wants what we need in his
immigration agenda in return so if Trump
is gonna give the dreamers any kind of
legal status I have a sensible checklist
of what he must demand in return and
this is all comporting with what he
campaigned on number one build the wall
get the funding and I'm not talking
about a puny down payment I was hearing
something about 1.6 billion from I think
speaker Ryan's office at one point we
need meaningful funding for the border
wall and that's a permanent structure
and not some chicken wire on the border
building the wall remains a top priority
for the voters in it is a promise that
must be fulfilled I know the president
is committed to that ending chain
migration this is one of the biggest
travesties of all time America used to
have a common sense policy of giving
priority to immigrants based on merit on
what they could contribute to our
society what we needed now basically all
you need is a second cousin twice
removed in the country and you'll get a
free pass no problem we have to return
to a practical system also we have to
end the joke of the diversity lottery
system about 50,000 people get in on
diversity alone and at a time when our
national security is threatened
I've already seen these examples of it
what's the point of admitting immigrants
at random this diversity lottery system
should never have been enacted and it
must end no questions asked there's
bipartisan support for that okay here's
one the business community is not going
to like make a verify mandatory
nationwide big business loves cheap
labor but we can't allow them to
undercut American workers any longer
forget about that can't do it and
finally we have to cut the number of
legal immigrants by reducing the number
of green card holders by half
50 percent that's basically the raise
act my friends trust Trump was not
elected to help the dreamers he was
elected to build the wall and force the
rule of law and protect the American
people
your move mr. president